DO NOT FEED THEIR POWER PLAY,
THEY'RE, THEY'RE CLICKING, IN 2T
MEETING.
SHOVELED TO THE THE RUN IT DOEST
WORK WORK OUT HERE COME THE BLUE
JACKETS.
AS THEY GET ON THELING UP A LOTF
E
FORECHECK THROUGH THE CROWD HE'S
LOOKING FOR HIS FIRST SINCE HIS
RETURN.
GOT
NOW CORRALY.
BLOCKER SAVE THERE,. SIDE.
THAT'S NYQUIST.
STEPS AWAY F WITH SO
MUCH PASSION YOU CAN SEE IT'S A
QUICK LAY AND
ZONE.
>> JONESSEN BEHIND THE NET FOR
WERENSKI.ALLBY.
PAINT,
UNABLE TOPOINT DEPREVENTED HIM M
GETTING UP FRONT.
>> RIGHT.
HERE ACROSS THE LIN THE
PERIOD.
WITH HIS WALL.
7.23 THEES HIM
OFF, MAKES THE MOVE, AND THEN
>> IF YOU HAD HATHAWAYNYQUIST TS
IC OUT.
CONNOR LOOKING FOR MCMIC IT UP T
SIDE.
MAKES THE SHOT SAVE.
BIG STOP, WE GO THE OTHER WAY IO
WERENSKI.
ZACH GETS IT
KORPISALO TAKES
JENNER WITH IT, HE'LL DROP IT
PUSHED AWAWATO HAGELIN.
HAGELIN STEERS TO THE ON THE PUA
HEAD'S